first
background to the g7 meeting back in
2015
countries agreed to keep human-induced
global warming to
two degrees preferably 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels
and as you can see on the climate show
dashboard scientists estimate
that we are currently at around 1.2
degrees and that number of course is
ticking up
all the time now the warming is caused
by burning fossil fuels which produce
greenhouse gases including carbon
dioxide
and earlier this week it was revealed
that in may
levels of co2 in the atmosphere reached
their highest level
since measurements began more than 60
years ago a monthly average
of just over 419 parts per million was
recorded
at the moana lao atmosphere baseline
observatory in hawaii now ppm
is the concentration of carbon in the
atmosphere that actually intensifies the
greenhouse effect
and warms our planet well scientists say
the only way out
of all of this is for countries but
especially the industrialized nations to
really reduce their emissions
but what chance is there of that were
with me now as our political editor
beth rigby we're keeping told beth don't
we that the climate is so important
at the g7 summit here but there's so
much else for the
politicians to be discussing what
will people be hoping that when sunday
comes and the leaders
leave will have been achieved when it
comes to the climate
well look i think the fast thing to say
is in his opening remarks boris johnson
said that he thought this was a huge
opportunity to tackle
climate change he says as a g7 we are
united
in our vision for a cleaner greener
world and if you look across
the g7 countries all have long term
targets to reach
net zero emissions by 2050 all have
confirmed their commitment
to holding temperature rises no more
than above 1.5
degrees celsius pre-industrial levels as
you were talking about
which is a lower end of the target set
in the paris agreements in 2015
so there is a lot of goodwill on the
part of the g7 but the big
elephant in the room is it's not
industrialized countries who are
set to emit most low carbon emissions in
the future more than 90 of emissions in
the next
two decades are expected to come from
emerging economies and that's why
activists and campaigners
want to see richer countries actually
help poorer countries to deal
with getting cleaner and greener there
was a pledge in 2009
for a hundred billion dollars a year
from public or private
sources to be given paid out to emerging
economies
to make their countries greener that was
a target which was meant to be hit
in 2020 will that be dusted down
at this summit and and the other big
elephant
in the room is china it's all very well
for the g7
to make commitments but as angela merkel
the outgoing german chancellor
said today we need everyone in the world
we want to work together particularly in
areas of climate change and biodiversity
we will never achieve solutions there
without china so again there's lots of
good will there's lots of talk
president biden has accelerated the u.s
carbon emission targets boris johnson is
leading the world in terms of cutting
emissions with the most ambitious
targets by 2030
and then 2035 but let's see what happens
at the end of the week because
really it's about developing economies
and what that comes down to is that the
g7 can make
targets but what they need to do is bind
in the g20
of course it's all linked to covid as
well isn't it because so many of those
developing countries
are having to spend their money on
dealing with the pandemic rather than
worrying about
about the climate and that sort of
brings me on to my next question beth um
boris johnson obviously hosting the
summit here he's also going to be
hosting cop 26 in november so the
pressure really is
on him isn't it to get results here
before the end of the year
yeah that's right the big challenge for
him is exactly that which is what can he
get countries to commit to now which he
can actually
roll into cop 26 and the truth of all of
it is despite
the talk from boris johnson and of
course president biden
over the issues of climate change
the big issue really here at the moment
is the pandemic
and vaccinations there are simply more
immediately
pressing issues but this is often the
way with climate change that it is the
crisis
that's always around the corner so there
is a plenary session as you said on
sunday
sir david attenborough will introduce
that
let's see what we come out with at the
end of the week but certainly at the
moment
in terms of tangible results and
outcomes from this
uh summit it really is on the
vaccination program and building back in
the short time around the pandemic
yeah we'll see what happens about those
elephants in the room thank you very
much indeed beth good to speak to you
well in today's other climate news half
of all plastic
in the world's oceans is from takeaway
food and drinks packaging
research published in nature
sustainability found that just 10
plastic items including lids food
wrappers
and containers make up 75 of the waste
scientists are calling for a ban on
common throwaway items
and for producers to be made to take
more responsibility
sea eagles have settled on loch lomond
in scotland for the first time in more
than a century a pair of white-tailed
eagles were first spotted at
lomond national nature reserve they're
now searching for suitable nest sites
suggesting they intend to save
almost half of clothes sold by online
fashion brands are made from entirely
new plastic
the royal society for the arts analyzed
10 000 items from retailers including
asos
and boohoo they found that on average 49
of clothes were made from new synthetic
fibers
and you can always catch up on today's
climate news on our website that's
skynews.com
climates
right let's show you our data dashboard
ben and at the top
we can see the real-time power mix it
shows where our electricity in great
britain
is coming from at the moment 46 is from
renewable sources
and the national grid break that down by
region as
well today in the southwest around 38
percent of power has come from
solar alone although it's not been
particularly sunny i have to say
that's much higher than the national
average of 13
cornwall is a leading county for clean
energy
with wind and geothermal projects also
based here that's all going to become
even more important of course as it's
set to become the first
net zero area of the uk now i've been
out and about today
finding out more about cornwall's green
revolution
cornwall's rugged skyline proudly
displays its industrial
past but what would cornish miners have
made of this
the green revolution dominating the
horizon today
as a g7 summit legacy the prime minister
has promised
cornwall will become the uk's first
region to be net zero
it is a bold ambition i met these
surfers who build boards from
sustainable materials
and plant trees in cornish soil the g7
leaders are just over there i think in
their hotel aren't they
at cabbage bay it sounds like you're
pretty skeptical that anything
decent is going to come out of that when
it comes to the climate well i mean
climate change science has been in for
50 years and nothing's changed
we all know what the data says we all
know that climate change is real
and what we need is big action and what
we normally get is a lot of waffle
this weekend the spotlight and the sun
is on cornwall's green
projects some work better than others
this wave scheme failed to turn the tide
of the climate crisis
so it's being turned into a floating
wind farm the celtic sea which is off
cornwall
is is has excellent wind resources for
us to come here it was a combination of
environmental benefits and a willingness
and partnership with the
local authorities summer and the summits
mean
cornwall's roads have never been busier
creating more nature reserves like this
one
is vital by restoring land like this
by more reforestation and improving
biodiversity the aim is for cornwall
to take 440 000 tons of carbon dioxide
out of its atmosphere once cornwall
provided most of the uk's tin
and copper can the county now provide a
blueprint
for a greener future
such a beautiful county great to be out
about today now coming up after
the break the masai community
digging for climate victory in kenya
prime minister boris johnson is of
course leading the g7
but a little bit later in the year at
the end of july he is co-hosting with
the president of kenya
a global education summit and at that
people will be asked to make pledges to
support the work of the global
partnership for education
we're saying raise your hand for
education and we are aiming to raise
at least u.s 5 billion
to make available to developing
countries to ensure that the most
marginalised children who
disproportionately tend to be girls
get into school at the height of it 1.6
billion children were out of school
but unlike here in many developing
countries there
aren't the mechanisms to maintain
educational continuity
using the technology that we're using
now so the global partnership for
education
stepped up to try and maintain
continuity through
radio tv lessons the provisions
sometimes
even of written pacs but we are
concerned that we
have experienced an earlier health
crises like ebola
that when schools close the most
marginalised children don't get back
particularly the girls who can be the
subject of child marriage
or put into child labour so one of the
things we are
certainly mobilizing for now and why we
need new resources
is to assist developing countries to
have great plans to put into action
to make sure every child comes back to
school if the pandemic has taught us
anything it is taught us that problems
behind one nation's borders don't stay
there
a problem in one country can become a
problem for the whole world
that's true of education if we don't
educate children
if we don't put nations on a pathway to
peace and prosperity
then those problems flow around the
world if we don't
vaccinate the whole world then we won't
be safe from covert 19.
actually these two things are linked in
the sense that we know from the evidence
that educated girls go on to become
mothers
who are more likely to have their
children vaccinated their children are
more likely to survive infant hood
and they're more likely to go to schools
themselves so we can get on
an upward cycle here with better health
outcomes through better education
outcomes
[Music]
hello my name is nadja francia
my name is brian matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west
antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
[Music]
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange for recyclable to get a tree
[Music]
hello again welcome back to a special
edition of the daily
climate show live from the g7 summit
taking place
here in cornwall now it's not only
global leaders gathering here this
weekend
blimps of boris and biden life-size
pokemon and even mermaids have all been
spotted
the light-hearted fancy dress and
costumes all part of
more serious demonstrations taking place
as sky's dan whitehead reports
well this is the first full day of
protests here at the g7 summit in
cornwall it all began
on the other side of the coast not here
in san is but over in falmouth where
there was a youth climate strike
it was the u.s president and uk prime
minister in blimp form
that started protests in falmouth young
campaigners gathered on the beach
to send their message
it's just absolutely crucial that
climate is on the agenda for this g7 not
just because
of the pivotal moment in which when with
the climate crisis and also leading up
to cop 26
but also because the countries that are
here have historic responsibility to act
on the climate
and a lot of countries who won't be at
this g7 are already experiencing the
impacts of that first
hand right now
that's the picture in falmouth here in
st ives extinction rebellion have been
holding
their first major protest it is climate
that is top
of the agenda more than 500 protesters
marched bruce and eyes
to be frank i feel we just need to come
to our senses
you know we could there's a lot of
science but actually if we come to our
senses
there are places i can't breathe because
of exhaustion
i want them to listen to what we're
saying and rather than just talking
about things
making a few policies and creating sound
bites
they need to take action
[Music]
well the process will continue right
throughout the weekend they are sending
a clear
message to the g7 leaders that it can't
just now be
about talk it's got to be about action
with climate change top of the agenda at
the summit
and amongst these protesters
now bangladesh is one of the country's
most at risk from climate change and
decisions that are going to be made here
in cornwall over the weekend could have
a real impact for the millions
who live there and the issue of climate
finance money from richer countries to
help developing nations reduce
emissions and increase resilience
against the negative impacts of climate
change
will be a big talking point but is
money the only thing that will help well
let's get more on this joining me now
from bangladesh is capital
dakar is professor salimul hook she's
director for the international center
for climate change and development good
to see you on the climate show
this evening thanks for being with us
sir now tell me
what are you hoping to hear from the
leaders
here at the g7 in cornwall
thank you very much for having me so
it's interesting that the
summit agenda uses the phrase climate
justice rather than just climate change
and there's nothing more unjust than
rich countries
causing the problem and poor countries
and poor people
suffering the consequences of their
pollution and therefore climate justice
requires
that these rich countries deliver on the
promises they have made in the past they
promised 100 billion dollars
to support the developing world in 2020
they didn't deliver it
and they owe another 20 100 billion for
2021
so we expect them to deliver on promises
not just repeat promises that they don't
deliver on
yeah you make a very good point about uh
those countries in the west where the g7
leaders uh
have traveled from being the polluters
and the developing
nations really struggling but of course
you're also struggling like all of us
are with the
covid pandemic how do we solve that
problem how do we make sure
that we get the world vaccinated whilst
at the same time making sure
everyone plays their part when it comes
to the climate crisis
you're absolutely right we are facing a
global pandemic
that we have to deal with and the
leaders there are going to have to deal
with it
i think the biggest challenge for them
each of them individually
is can they rise to the challenge of
acting like global leaders
solving global problems by the richest
seven countries
or are they going to be hunkering down
in their own national
leadership and do whatever is best for
their own countries and the rest can be
beggar
thy neighbor which unfortunately with
vaccinations they've done
vaccinated themselves and only now
talking about vaccinating the rest of
the world
well we should get a clearer idea of
course of what the leaders
uh come up with uh on sunday for now
professor sally mulhook
from bangladesh thank you very much for
joining us
now as we've been hearing the effects of
climate change are already being felt
right around the world but there are
solutions
in africa farmers are on a mission to
restore
areas affected by our changing climate
southern kenya
suffers from extended droughts and
irregular rains but nature-based
solutions can help re-green the land
improving
biodiversity crops and also the water
[Music]
supply
[Music]
i remember when i was young in the 90s
when i was growing
there there was a lot of a lot of rain
and everything was grass and
years we were controlling the adobe
market now there's no
even if we are anywhere you are climate
change will actually affect you whatever
because if it affect me
then it will affect you
[Music]
are you hopeful for the future of
climate change
[Music]
yes i hope hope
if we do something like initiative like
just dig it where we
we have now bands like this and control
the little water that we get from rain
i think that's the hope we have
and that was a live edition of the
climate show
from here in cornwall and there's plenty
more coverage of the g7
coming up this evening here on sky news
do stay with us but if you're missing
your climate fix
over the weekend then you can tune into
climate cast
on this week's episode to kick off euro
2020
we're asking can football tackle climate
change
that's available wherever you normally
get your podcasts from
and on our weekly digital show find out
how celebrities are using
instagram to persuade their followers to
be more sustainable
that will be available on sky news
social channels on our app
and on our website from saturday morning
and the daily climate show we'll be back
at our usual time half by six in our
usual studio
from monday thanks for watching we'll
see you then and i'll have all the
latest from the g7
summit here in cornwall in a few minutes
time
[Music]
you